the hands band samurai to life
i wouldn't write these lyrics for myself
[Music]
so it's kind of interesting to to get
into like the mindset of
who is this character and what would
they write about what what's their
agenda
[Music]
it's interesting to to try to like catch
a language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
part of this game
[Applause]
there is a reason why we're here
[Music]
it was piotr maybe who was a fan of the
band
he knew refused and he knew my voice and
he's oh that's a perfect voice for
for johnny
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when johnny's supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy gonna
drag a corporal rat on stage
make them kneel douse it with gas then
light them up so of course there are
things that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this rebel
that's fighting against like the the
corporates and
that's definitely something that's been
a part of my life and a part of the
fuselage
we came out of the punk rock scene of
northern sweden
he's like the future version of us
[Music]
so i think it makes sense i think it
totally makes sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him
so it's pretty cool
yeah no no no no but
yeah but like white vibrato
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't have a different mode than just
going
all in so we really work on these songs
trying to make them as good as possible
then they're not actually our songs it's
interesting as
as a musician to play another musician
because that's essentially what we're
doing i mean we're not here
as refused we're here samurai and i'm
here
with johnny it's still around you know
so it's like the voice we're
representing here is someone else
it's been a mind [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get down
[Music]
i mean the shouting in itself is just
like second nature to me because i've
been i've been doing this for a very
long time
but then when someone comes in and says
i'm happy with everything except for as
a limb
again it's as a as a
i think okay
the shouting is great but think of that
accent so think of that like enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very different way of singing
when you're screaming like that and it's
hard to sort of
swallowing some syllables there adjust
your accent
oh yeah just try it again so it's it's
been a bit
frustrating it wasn't it wasn't
[Music]
it wasn't horrible but it wasn't great
but i mean i get it i mean
we have to maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is
me like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know you you think the things like the
rhythm and you think about the pitch and
you think about all these things but
then someone comes in and like
that word sounded weird i'm like what no
that's how i sing
but so it's been a very uh yeah
very painful at times
it's all right see it is soon i'm
chipping
in roll the boots out chip in
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of as as a person that's not a gamer
i don't think i fully understand the
impact that this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
then that's gonna be great i mean we are
spending a lot of time
trying to get this right trying to get
it to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting it's a very
different way of
of making music actually
you can already find three samurai
tracks available on streaming services
chipping in never fade away and the
ballad of buck ravers
but we're excited to announce a fourth
new song
called a like supreme which is coming to
streaming services today
that means you can check it out once the
show is over don't forget that if you're
tuning in late or if you just want to
watch anything again we will be
uploading everything to our channel soon
next up pavel and i are going to
introduce you to some
creative ways that you can solve
problems in night city